welcome back to new rock stars I'm Danny
Burke asked E and we've got a hot new
trailer for the new Star Wars Disney
Plus series the Mandalorian if you
missed our first look at this series you
should totally go back and check out our
breakdown of the trailer that Disney
dropped at d23 actually this trailer has
a lot of shots in common with the first
one but with a lot of details filled in
and with a few interesting twists so
we're gonna break down this video for
all the details that you might have
missed spoiler warning our analysis
might be so good that we guess exactly
what's gonna go down in the series and
if that happens sorry not sorry so let's
get into it
[Music]
it's a lot more peaceful since a
revolution it is a shame that you have
people suffered these first two shots
are exactly the same as the previous
trailer something new that we do get is
very hedgehogs character who we now know
is referred to mysteriously as the
client giving us a bit of exposition it
sounds to me like he's asking the
question it's a world more peaceful
innocence a revolution a question that
would line up well with the Imperial
loyalists that we assume his character
to be but the captions on the official
upload of the trailer suggests that he's
making a statement in a bit of yoga
speak it's a world more peaceful rather
than is the world more peaceful he
continues it just ashamed to tell people
subtle making it sound as though the
people of the planet Mandalore were
scapegoated in the fall of the Empire
moving on a fight scene hell yeah we see
the Mandalorian ambushed by a group of
kleh to nians a race that used to be
employed by the Hutts
keep that in mind he defeats them all in
a hand-to-hand combat thanks to his
superior armor and weaponry but
seriously take a look at this he sends
one flying backwards with a blast of
what I would like to call his shocky
bayonets and here one of the clue to
nians brings his blade down directly on
the Mandalorian shoulder plate only to
have it bounce off harmlessly this is
going to be a theme so watch out for it
as we move on to the rest of the trailer
but bounty hunting is a complicated
process
bounty hunting is a complicated
profession huh is it it seems pretty
straightforward to me from these few
shots you freeze the baddies in
carbonite I guess we can thank Darth
Vader and Boba Fett for that innovation
then you haul them off to wherever
you're gonna get paid for them easy
peasy on in the next clip they said you
were coming
they sit who are the best in the parsec
we already saw this shipyard in town in
the previous trailer but now we have a
bit more context this is where the goods
need to be dropped off and it looks like
a hotbed of bounty hunting activity
being the best apparently the
Mandalorian has to deal with the
jealousy and ire of his peers in the
background here you can see an orange
rhodium Greedo the first ever bounty
hunter to appear in star wars was a
rhodium oh and by the way he was hired
by Jabba the Hutt to capture han Solo
remember that onward which go pre look
at him go you BAE's the best in the
parsec vana you creepy old imperialist
you I love the sound cue in this first
shot which sounds like a speeder bike
like the one we saw the Mandalorian
riding in the first trailer coming to a
crashing halt the sound cue just adds to
the Leto feel of the shot like oh sorry
wrong door I'll just let you gentlemen
get back to whatever it was you were
doing with all of your blasters out what
are they doing by the way it looks like
searching through some cargo perhaps
looking for contraband perhaps they're
in the cargo hold of a ship just waiting
for the Mandalorians so they can ambush
him but we all know by now how he does
in ambushes they bounce off his armor
like a clipped onion blade or a laser
blast seriously what is that armor made
of and where can I get something moving
up
[Music]
all right now we're getting into the
juicy stuff we're seeing a family in red
fleeing a city besieged by b-2 super
battle droids
I want to guess that this is a flashback
and we are seeing the suffering the
client says was inflicted on the
Mandalorians people these two actors are
Alexandra Minaya and Bernard Bowen and
on IMDB they are listed as mother and
father which I think would make this
child a young Pedro Pascal he's got a
chip on his shoulder and he's ready for
payback
the choice of droids are another
indicator that this sequence is a
flashback as they appeared in the
prequels during the Clone Wars
maybe this scene represents the siege of
Mandalore which was led by Darth Maul
and given all of our speculation about
mauls role in the new trilogy
maybe this flashback includes the big
spoiler that were supposedly going to
get about episode 9 then we see the
Mandalorian lasso this Quarren this shot
is exactly the same as the last trailer
but flipped why in the new trailer they
have the Mandalorian facing toward the
right it's a loose tradition in western
films as onra that this series clearly
draws significantly from that in a
showdown the good guys walk from left to
right and the bad guys walk from right
to left I think that the last trailer
left the moral position of the
Mandalorian to ambiguous who is this guy
what does he want and why does he almost
certainly bisect this poor Quarren this
trailer is all about giving context to
answer those questions and establish the
Mandalorian as a good guy he blasts the
door a shot notably absent from this
trailer
only after the Quarren fires first the
blast once again deflecting off of those
wonderful shoulder plates this reminds
me of the old question of who shot first
Han or Greedo which was already alluded
to by the presence of morodian earlier
in this trailer
later edits of the new Hope had Greedo
clearly shooting first so that we could
stay on Han side as the good guy in that
very scene we see the tradition played
out Hans on the Left shooting to the
right next clip
and then DeLorean a look outside
of waiting for you
look at this we see a woman reaching to
remove the Mandalorians mask moments
after we hear the client refer to him
simply as Mandalorian we've yet to see a
shot of his unobscured face it seems
like the mystery of who he is will be
important to the series this reminds me
of the Lone Ranger
which I now think will be a large
influence on this series who was that
masked man anyway I guess that might
make IG 11 Tonto moving on to the final
clip yeah
the last shot we get is a Pedro Pascal's
character aiming his rifle toward the
right of the screen and the last word we
hear him say as we finally get to hear
the dreamy man's dreamy dreamy voice is
good okay so now remember all those
folks who worked for the huts that I
told you to remember well one that I
didn't mention is this guy tessick he
was an accountant for Jabba the Hutt and
he's guess what a Quarren there are so
many ties to the Hutts
a crime family that employed many bounty
hunters that perhaps this very Quarren
that the Mandalorian scuffles with is
tesak and perhaps a big part of this
series will be bounty hunters turning on
the crime empire that formerly
bankrolled them what do you think the
Mandalorian will be about comment below
follow me on twitter and instagram at
Danny Paz and make sure to subscribe to
new rock stars for all your Star Wars
breakdown needs oh hey and check out our
podcast WikiLeaks thanks for joining me
now seriously I'm going to figure out
where I can get some of that sick
Mandalorian armor
[Music]